if you're anything like me you may have
watched some videos on YouTube about
coding where someone has created a
program that teaches their computer to
play snake or play Tetris or generate
YouTube video scripts I've watched a lot
of these and they've always focused on
the end result it makes the end result
seem inevitable like here's the thing
which I did and here are all the steps I
did perfectly in order to make it I
don't think that's how most people
program so in this video I want to try
something different I want to try and do
a coding vlog I wanna make this video
we're going to take you in this camera
around with me as I try and program as a
particular task I've been challenged by
Robo race this is a sponsored video
sponsored video everyone this was
sponsored by Robo race I've been
challenged by them to teach my computer
how to drive now I'm not actually gonna
put my computer behind the wheel of a
car it can barely run Skyrim as it is so
instead I'm gonna be teaching it how to
drive on a 2d racing circuit a bit like
a kind of flash mini game and this blog
is gonna focus on the journey of how I
did that because well if you've watched
my videos before you may be aware of I'm
not the world's greatest programmer
why are you I'm filming this at the
start this is probably gonna take two
maybe three weeks so you'll see me
change clothes a couple of times maybe
maybe you'll see me get a haircut oh and
we'll find out if one well I can
actually do the programming because we
felt convinced that I can and two if
this format works if the coding vlog
works no one's ever tried this as far as
I could tell so I've identified some key
things which we need to learn how to do
in order to make this project work the
first of them is how to make a
continually refreshing graphical
representation of what's going on inside
the code in other words only to learn
how to make a game window something that
refreshes a certain number of times a
second is populated by objects and
allows me to see what's going on
secondly I need to learn how to make the
object in that representation interact
with the environment and specifically if
objects are cars I need them to know the
distance between them and the wall of
the racing track in front of them to the
side of them you know in a couple of
directions that information then goes
into how those objects behave in other
words how they drive and you know we're
gonna have the typical controls for a
flash game for Driving's of W a s and D
something like that then after
comes the actual machine learning where
I'm gonna have to learn how to do some
genetic programming where we generate a
huge number of cars at the start of a
race given the ones which perform best
we breed them and produce a new
generation and we do that several times
until we hopefully end up with some cars
that actually know how to drive then
we'll need to test if the cars have
learned to drive or if they've learned
to drive on the specific test track that
I've been working on by testing them out
on other tracks I have no doubt that
this plan will not survive contact with
the data because that's what my plans
tend to do but that I think is what I
need to do that's the broad outline oh
and I'm gonna be working in Python
because life's too short and I already
know my way around the language
apologies if this isn't the best
language to use but it's the one I'm
gonna stick with okay so after that
initial foray and about a day or so of
on and off programming here's where I'm
at so this is a game window which I've
coded up in PI game I started out in
arcade but that was just to simple
module I had to switch over to PI game
because I had so much more functionality
those who don't know what programming
modules are basically it's a series of
instructions it's like a toolkit the
toolkit I started out with was great
because it was easy to understand but it
wasn't complicated enough to even
replicate something like Super Mario
Brothers so I switched over to PI game
because you could do so much more with
it where at the moment is that I have a
particle which represents the car in the
game and I could actually import any
number of them that completely scales to
any number of cars I've won and that car
has a position it has a velocity it has
an angle for this velocity of that in
the space and it has other
characteristics you can give it like
acceleration for example what you've
seen on the screen here is its distance
to the black walls the white here
represents the track and the black
represents the track walls it was just
something that I drew freehand and in
Photoshop and it's a bitmap the numbers
on the top right corresponds to the
distance from the center of the car to
the wall looking at the left hand field
of view the center of its field of view
and the right of its field of view and
the field of view is a custom number
that can be dialed in custom for each
car what you may notice is that it
doesn't bounce off of the walls of the
track it just bounces off the widt edge
of the window I need to implement that I
was I was very pleased to get it
bouncing off of the walls that's a job
that I'm gonna come to you tomorrow and
when that's done that's all
everything that I need to do in terms of
setting up the game done and we can move
on to the actual machine learning that's
something that I'm going to need to do
tomorrow though because because today is
my anniversary it's our fourth
anniversary I actually did on the
channel for a while oh yeah as pixel
girl and we are currently in the Gherkin
in London because there is a restaurant
on the very top
[Music]
unfortunately the way that's not amazing
for the best view of all is right here
okay so much has happened since
yesterday and I do have ever been so
excited for a coding project in my
entire life let me take you through what
I've done this is the latest version of
the game running so what you see is that
the cars are now bouncing off of the
walls I implemented that it was actually
surprisingly easy to do I basically just
copied the interactions between pixels
when they hit balls but just with
checking if the pixel that they're
running into is black or white I've also
updated the race so you can see actually
how far it is between that particle and
the wall in its field of view well you
might also notice this of the field of
view how narrow the cone is is specific
to each car right so it varies from
quake to Stevie Wonder that's a random
number that gets assigned within the
class of the particle when you call it
now the cool thing about this though the
really cool thing is that these cars are
driving based on the information that
they're getting from the environment so
depending on how far they are in each of
those directions and also how fast
they're going at the time they're
choosing whether or not to press WASD in
other words whether they want to
accelerate brake turn left or turn right
the way that I've accomplished this is a
simple bit of linear algebra you have a
vector representing your distance in
each of the direction plus your speed
that's like a column vector and then you
have a matrix that you're multiplying
that by when you multiply that vector by
the matrix you're going to get another
vector which gives you a series of
numbers if those numbers are beyond a
certain threshold which I've just said
to be zero completely arbitrarily that
corresponds to whether they press a
button or not on that particular tick
that like time step of moving forward in
the game whether at that moment they are
pressing a key down or not those key
presses then go into this line of code
where it shows you whether or not the
effect of acceleration or brake or turn
left or turn right is being implemented
so referring back to the list that I do
at the start of the video all the things
I need to do we now have the game engine
working and we have the particles
interacting with their environment like
this is one way smoother than I thought
it was now Herber comes the technically
difficult bit now we need to do the
genetic programming we need to take the
cars which do best on this track and
then make more
them the question is though how do you
assess how well a car is doing on this
track what we need is a school function
so they paint one or on my lunch breaks
by the way it helps me relax a score
function is a generic way of keeping
track of how well a particular version
of the algorithm is working so humans
have a pretty good idea of what a school
function for race driving looks like it
means you go around the track fast
that's a problem though for the computer
when it doesn't know what the track is
or for that matter which is the right
way to go around the track to it it's
just a bunch of pixels and in many ways
a lot of successfully using machine
learning is choosing the right school
function to try and maximize or minimize
so I tried loads of different versions
including the angle that the car's gone
around the track so if it starts off at
zero degrees it completes the track and
has gone through 360 degrees but that
didn't quite work god this is
multitasking this apps the finest
I'm painting terrain by the way because
I got so sick to death of the black and
slightly off black of my highfalutin
Nostromo tyranids so what I decided to
use was the way that we assess it in
video games and in real life races I
suppose checkpoints it's you can reach
certain checkpoints around the track
fastest and one of those checkpoints is
the finish line the key advantage of
this technique is that it it has a
direction built into it the cars can
only go around the track one way they
have to clear the checkpoints in order
so yes in theory you could go all the
way around the track and hit the first
checkpoint but you're gonna do so much
slower than a car that goes the right
way around the track so if you build in
number of checkpoints hit and the amount
of time taken to hit those checkpoints
then you're gonna have some winning
combination the exact details you can
work out after the fact with some
experimentation so here are the
checkpoints on the screen you'll see
these red dots which corresponds to the
individual checkpoints and you also
the cars and our different covers I
thought would add a color to each car
because it allow us to see which cars
are successful in going forwards to the
next generation the way them the way how
the way that the code works to check if
it reaches a checkpoint is that there's
a function now which is update score
that's associated with each particle and
what it will do is check if the next
checkpoint and it starts out as one if
the next checkpoint is within 30 pixels
of the position of the car if that's the
case then it counts as having gotten
that checkpoint and the next checkpoint
is updated and it's now looking for
checkpoint two and it means that it's
got a score of one if it's reached the
first checkpoint that gets divided by
the time taken now comes the fun part
because now I need to write a function
which is going to first of all work out
which of these particles does the best
which are the which of the cars is best
performing over say 30 seconds blanks
all of their scores and it'll take the
top 10% and that will be our parents for
the next generation much much sooner
than expected I think we've got it
working so I wrote a function which
allows the particles to breathe
basically it will for each of their
characteristics for the elements of the
array there's a random chance of
inheriting each of those from his
parents plus a little extra mutation
chance on top so there's like a small
variability on top of it but it's like
much smaller than what it inherits from
its parents and the color is a mix of
the two and the field of view is also a
random chance between the two that's
working I think I'm getting good at
programming guys I think it's actually
happening
if you moments later that me that has
that made it work I know hang on hang on
being stupid yeah at least five second
generations let's just see if this works
oh my god programming is amazing
oh how sick is that so now what I want
to do is based on that initial
experiment the cars weren't really
learning to drive throw basically did
bundling around the track so I'm just
gonna make them lose a lot more momentum
when they crash so that's basically
changing the elasticity of the
I'm using lose more kinetic energy when
they crash I never thought I'd be able
to do this this is so cool what's
interesting is after watching this for a
while all of the cars have become Brown
that's probably just because if you take
an average of lots of colors they're
eventually just gonna become Brown
rather than you know it was a brown car
that did particularly well this is
fascinating to watch I know that's
interesting in that generation there was
a car that did quite well that was blue
that was a wild car so it was a new one
and in fact the new cars on this
generation are doing well are slightly
like brownie blue the ones that are
being successful other ones that go
forward and turn right because the first
checkpoint is a right turn that's super
interesting though that some of them
like a significant fraction are still
going on when we're on the track I need
to tweak this okay right bit later made
some changes so what I realized was
there was a left over in my code for
when I initially sort of set up the
individual drivers initially I was just
testing them in random angles and random
locations so the starting angle was
still random which is why so many
drivers were going the wrong way around
they weren't all pointing in the same
direction now I'm on generation three of
the new version they're almost all going
the right way around the track and
what's interesting actually is that the
field view that they need has narrowed
massively there's still some which have
gotten a wide field of view never ever
thought that I would sort of get so into
watching tiny pixels get on screen for
yeah they've all mutated into having
like a really narrow field of view they
only see what's in front of them they
didn't see what's on the side of them ah
there's a purple guy that's just made it
in though the big field of view is doing
quite well oh I say that it's just
compact quick I also made a change to
how the breeding works basically um the
way that it worked before was if you
were in the cutoff of the top 10% or
whatever it was you stood an equal
chance of having offspring you produce
the same number of offspring as
everybody else but I wanted to make it
such that the higher your school was
within that cutoff the more children you
were gonna have so rewards performance
within that bracket so now
the number of children that you have is
inversely proportional to your rank I
think it's happening I tweaked how it
learned I tweet the variant the weights
of the parameters like I realized that
the scale of for example the speed
versus the distance was gonna be
completely different
I've noticed that they weren't turning
which kind of told me that the distance
to the walls wasn't important to the
drivers it was just the speed but with
fog this has just started the fifth
generation is like a bunch of lilacs
there's a little bit green showing
through but look they're turning they do
move in herds now what's interesting is
they've now reached the one can turn
they have to turn left just pretty much
everything else I just had to turn right
and so what they're doing is they're all
going into that turning and going to
move straight into the wall they have to
learn to turn left as well like there
has to be the possibility in their
programming I suppose they do turn left
actually there's like a kink before oh I
also added a lot more checkpoints I
realized that there just weren't enough
checkpoints and then I how important
reaching each one was by the time taken
to reach it yeah oh my God look at them
actually learn something I built in code
works there's a bunch of front runners
okay I know good good into the wall like
a bundle Elevens all it takes is like
one driver to work out that they can
turn left oh oh one of them learns how
to look what I made it and what was it
it was particle what 11:04 whole new
sport so that's interesting the previous
generation there was a car that went
almost the entire way around but this
time around didn't work that was just a
chance mutation you know like having a
really gifted parent doesn't mean you're
gonna have a really gifted child like my
mum amazingly musically talented I'm not
so much although
I got look he's gonna give a [ __ ] that's
to that we're going all the way around
please tell me that it's not gonna crash
because it goes all the way around oh my
god watch because there's two of them
that means that there will be two over
there will be an offspring of those two
so how many of each generation do we
keep we're keeping ten the first ten of
each generation as definitely tenders
made it all the way around now so now it
is this is when the timing aspect comes
into it it's like all of you have made
it around
no it's which one of you is fastest this
is so cool okay I think we've taught a
computer how to drive around a track
around one track I am dead chuffed with
that that is so cool okay next though
that's that's I think three of the
things which I said I need you to do
we've got the game working we've got the
objects interacting with the game world
and we've got them going around a track
now we need to test if the cars can go
around another track or if they've just
learned this one right so it's much
later in the month I've spent the last
week or two just tweaking the models
here and there and training staff and
experimenting actually we're not to see
pizza girl's family and snuck away for a
couple of hours in a coffee shop rated
most of this work I've trained a final
generation of drivers based on all this
experimentation and I've drawn a new map
in Photoshop which means that we have
our final test we're gonna find out oh
so now we're gonna find out if the cars
have overfit to the training days or if
they actually know how to drive
so I've pointed the scripts to the new
map and let's see what happens
ah a bunch of cars are stuck in the
walls I think the the star of the race
may have been a slightly different
location let me just let me just fix
that you may have noticed by the way
that I've changed the look of the track
so there is now an indication of what
each car is doing so whether it's
pressing WASD or not so it's interesting
to watch that actually because it
doesn't behave quite as a human would
okay I should have moved the starting
position the cars let's see how this
works right so we've got all the cars so
the cars have learned to go around the
track not necessarily in the right
direction some of them have got confused
and gone the wrong direction but they
are driving they oh I don't think any of
them have actually got all the way
around yeah okay no at least one has
gone all the way around so that's
interesting this was a wildly different
track ahead long straights I had way
tighter turns than they had to deal with
in the training track but they are going
around the right way and for the most
part they're actually picking a
direction and sticking to it what you
may notice by the way is that the cars
always are always practicing w which is
what humans do when they're playing on
these games but a lot of the time
instead of pressing a or D they actually
just tend to press both at the same time
and then they'll lift off whichever key
they is in the direction they don't want
to go in which to a human sounds insane
but to a computer kind of makes sense so
it makes no difference to them but I
think we can count that as a success I
mean yes the cars weren't necessarily
going the right way around the track
well I'm quite sure why that didn't
happen but they were avoiding the walls
they were taking good racing lines and
taking corners nice and tight I mean I
see this as an absolute wind
now what done here is actually pretty
simple it's taking in a couple of input
parameters applying some linear algebra
and then letting a car decide if it
wants to press W a s or D real driving
is a lot more complicated than that and
there are cars which can autonomously go
around racetracks and I went to go and
see them in action
rubber race for testing out a variety of
their cars at the shells Li Walsh Hill
Climb these cars are just like my
virtual ones and that they take in the
distance from the car to the track wall
and make a decision about where they're
going to drive but they're much more
complex they also use lidar these GPS
they take into account the friction
coefficient between their tires and the
road they also look absolutely stunning
if you'd like to learn more about the
science behind these cars and how they
drive themselves check out a link in the
description to videos about the
technology and also about season alpha
the first round of competitions between
these cars taking place around the world
you can also check out their Instagram
and there'll be a link to my github
where you can take a look at the code I
use in this video thank you robo race
for sponsoring this series of videos and
of course thank you for watching I'll
see you in the next one